bonsoir
bonsoir madame donc on a quelques pièces
du casse-tête surtout grâce au travail
des médias mais si on avait toutes les
pièces
ce qu'on verrait quel est le but de la
Chine qu'est-ce qu'elle veut faire en
essayant d'influencer par exemple les
élections
plus la Chine gagne en puissance plus
surtout depuis entre autres l'accession
pouvoir de
Sylvin
en puissance plus elle veut se projeter
à l'étranger intervenir
influencer et ce qu'on voit ce sont des
des signes de ça maintenant le cette
influence là elle le problème de cette
influence là c'est quand elle dépasse
des bornes comme par exemple
l'intervention dans notre processus
démocratique mais aussi quand elle quand
elle se fait sous forme d'espionnage
quand bon alors là on assiste donc avec
toutes les révélations et d'ailleurs ce
qu'on voit ce sont principalement des
extraits de rapport du SARS des services
secrets canadiens et puis il y a eu hier
le fameux rapport Rosenberg mais ce
qu'on voit c'est vraiment un cas
d'utilisation de la communauté chinoise
au Canada de la part du gouvernement
chinois pour intervenir dans le
processus électoral canadien c'est pas
nouveau que la Chine utilise
c'est ressortissant à l'étranger il y a
même une grande organisation en Chine
qui s'appelle le front uni qui est de
plus en plus subventionné par le
gouvernement central chinois pour
prendre contact avec les communautés
chinoises à l'étranger pour projeter à
travers ces communautés là et à travers
et avec l'aide de ces communautés là
qu'elle le veuille ou dans d'ailleurs
selon les rapports il y a des gens qui
ont été plus ou moins intimidés par les
diplomates chinois au Canada pour
intervenir dans nos élections dans nos
élections mais au Canada il y a un
milliard 800 millions de Chinois tous ne
sont pas d'allégeance
et un million 200 millions
et donc ces gens-là c'est une force sur
laquelle le gouvernement chinois compte
pour augmenter son influence dans le
pays je reviens à cette influence vous
dites plus elle gagne en plus puissance
plus elle veut influencer
influencer pour faire quoi et de
influencer pour dans quelle direction
encore une fois selon ce qu'on peut lire
selon ce qu'on peut voir et tout ça le
gouvernement chinois aurait voulu avoir
devant lui au Canada un gouvernement
moins
disons moins agressif à l'endroit de la
Chine moins critique face à la Chine que
le gouvernement que qu'on a connu sous
la période Harper et Monsieur Trudeau
est perçu comme un personnage plus
conciliant pour ne pas dire plus
malléable ça ça c'est c'est aussi
peut-être un aspect important ce qui est
un peu contradictoire dans tout ça c'est
que on a à la fois une un gouvernement
canadien qui dans la nouvelle politique
indopacifique de madame Joly
traite la Chine de pouvoir déstabilisant
dans le monde et on a un gouvernement au
pouvoir on a un premier ministre au
pouvoir qui lui dit
il n'y a pas eu d'influence réelle qui a
changé les résultats de l'élection donc
on ne voit pas de nécessité d'aller plus
loin dans dans la quête de
renseignements sur cette influence
réelle là moi je pense est important
d'en savoir plus compte tenu de tout ce
qui est sorti dans les médias et même
dans le rapport Rosenberg oui tout ce
qui est sorti dans les médias donc on a
parlé du but mais justement vous avez
fait allusion ou méthode d'essayer de
privilégier des candidats grâce à la
diaspora sur place est-ce que c'est des
tactiques courantes de la Chine au-delà
de ce qui se passe au Canada
ouais c'est intéressant parce qu'il y a
un exemple qui est qui ressemble un peu
au modèle canadien c'est l'Australie
l'Australie dès 2017 a commencé vraiment
à adopter toute une série de mesures
législatives parce que ça se passait en
Italie en Australie pardon à une échelle
beaucoup plus grande au Canada pourquoi
bien sûr parce que l'Australie est un
partenaire commercial important de la
Chine est un pays dans la zone
d'influence de la Chine très important
donc il y avait un contrôle de la
situation en Chine dans les univers en
Australie dans les universités même dans
les ministères des gouvernements
qui s'exercait à travers en grande
partie la communauté chinoise en
Australie à travers des riches chinois
qui
investissaient dans les campagnes
électorales des candidats qu'il voulait
voir élus et ça a été tellement
important cette influence là qu'à un
moment donné en 2017 le gouvernement du
premier ministre Morrison si je me
souviens bien à l'époque a décidé
d'adapter une loi pour interdire les
contributions d'étrangers dans le
processus électoral et contributions
financières dans le processus électoral
australien la majorité de ces
contributions là étaient faites par des
chinois après ça il y a eu toute une
série de mesures pour contrôler
l'influence du pour contrôler
l'espionnage bref l'Australie qui était
pris avec ce problème là s'est réveillé
un moment donné où c'était très
important l'influence de la Chine et la
l'influence que la Chine avait même sur
l'adoption de politique en Australie que
la Chine a fait quelque chose que
l'Australie a fait quelque chose de très
important et là il est temps que le
Canada qui définit justement dans les la
perspective de madame Joly la Chine
comme un pouvoir perturbateur se rendent
compte de ce qui se passe et adopte des
mesures monsieur Champagne a déjà adopté
des mesures pour empêcher par exemple
les entreprises chinoises d'investir
dans des mines de métaux stratégiques au
Canada très on n'a pas du tout
l'équivalent de ce genre de droit là en
Chine ensuite on est intervenu récemment
Madeleine vous le savez dans tout ce qui
attrape la recherche qui se fait en
commun entre la Chine et parce qu'ils
n'ose universités dans un climat de
naïveté absolument invraisemblable ou en
collaborait entre autres ça a été un
exemple qui a été cité avec l'Institut
militaire de recherche militaire le plus
important en Chine fondée par Mao à
l'époque donc des niveaux de
collaboration qui remettaient en
question notre technologie militaire la
plus sophistiquée et nausées nos
renseignements militaires les plus
sophistiqués donc il est temps que on se
rend compte de du degré de cette
influence là au Canada et l'intervention
dans le processus électoral ça s'est
fait en 2015 ça s'est fait en 2019 et ça
s'est fait à une échelle encore plus
systématique parce que toutes les gens
apprennent à mieux à mieux performer en
2021 et on en a des exemples à votre
avis Jean-François Lépine lorsque vous
voyez ce qui se passe en ce moment
comment réagit le régime chinois est-ce
qu'il est content qu'il y a un petit peu
de Bizzbee dans sur toute la question
l'ingérence électorale où ça fait pas
son affaire est-ce que quelle est la
réaction intrinsèque de la Chine en ce
moment
je pense pas que les Chinois soient
contents que tout ça se débattent en
public on le voit un petit peu avec
toute l'histoire de la covid dans les
chinois ne veulent pas qu'on qu'on
questionne leur comportement quel qu'il
soit et je pense qu'ils sont pas très
contents de ce qui se passe actuellement
au Canada d'ailleurs les diplomates
canadiens l'ont dit les diplomates
chinois au Canada ont déjà émis des
commentaires sur tout ça en parlant de
rumeurs etc mais ce ne sont plus de des
rumeurs lorsqu'on voit dans les journaux
ce qui est issus des renseignements de
l'espionnage de des agences de
renseignements canadien c'est
extrêmement concret on parle
d'utilisation de pression sur des
étudiants chinois pour qu'ils
travaillent dans les ailes qui soient
des travailleurs électoraux pour faire
élire des députés on parle de
contribution ça c'est important aussi
c'est qu'à travers toutes sortes
d'intermédiaires chinois Canadiens on
donne des contributions aux partis
politiques et qui sont après ça
remboursés par le gouvernement chinois
ça a été phénomène qui s'est passé avec
le fameux dons à la Fondation
Pierre-Elliot Trudeau et à l'Université
de Montréal en 2016 au lendemain de
l'élection de 2015 ça fait longtemps que
tout ça dure ça fait longtemps que ça se
ça se fait de façon extrêmement subtile
mais là ça devient de plus en plus
évident et il y a un phénomène Madeleine
sur lequel il faut se poser des
questions c'est pourquoi tout d'un coup
ces rapports des services secrets
Canadiens sortent de tout bas tout court
et des services de renseignement
canadien
des gens qui veulent que des actions
soient prises en ce moment oui mais en
même temps il faut se poser la question
est-ce que ça fait partie de la
démocratie canadienne que les services
de renseignement canadien laisse filtré
comme ça des enquêtes extrêmement
confidentielles extrêmement socket c'est
une bonne question aussi à poser mais il
y a une urgence de d'avoir plus de
transparence dans ce dossier là qui pour
l'instant se résume à des révélations
des fuites dans journaux des reportages
extrêmement bien faits par ailleurs mais
et ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est de
noter que la Commission dit le rapport
of dit il y a pas assez de de preuves
suffisante pour montrer qu'il y a eu une
influence dans le processus électoral
d'accord mais on se retourne et on dit
mais à l'avenir il faudrait quand même
informer les candidats les députés et
tout ça de la façon de se protéger
contre ce genre d'influence là donc y
a-t-il ou non une influence on est en
contradiction là Jean-François Lépine
merci pour vos lumières c'était fort
fort apprécié merci beaucoup au revoir